welcome back to new rockstars i'm eric
voss and this is a breakdown of rick and
morty season five episode one
mort dinner rick andre a title based on
the 1981 andre gregory wallace shawn
film
my dinner with andre which actually also
inspired a season two episode of dan
harmon's other major series community
now rick and morty as a series loki the
years before i decided loki was a verb
so i'm taking a break from some loki
coverage to go back breaking down
all the easter eggs all the subtle jokes
and horny animation details you may have
missed in this rick and morty season
premiere so morty carries a badly
wounded rick away from some mystery
mission against a tentacled monster that
feeds on these floating crystals
depicting
alternate realities kind of like the
four beaujolais crystals in season four
but they don't all appear to be death
futures
we see brick with the lava gun morty and
rickett's birds fighting over a worm
morty cradling a baby rick
them as lego bricks a greaser morty
morty and rick passing an upholstery
store
lumberjack rick chopping down a morty
tree and of course a blade reality with
these vampire djs looking like the same
very pirates we saw back in season two
another showing doc and marty justin
roland's crude channel 101 short that
rick and morty was initially based on
if you like this show trust me don't go
back and watch that then rick and morty
as 18th century british soldiers
one in which rick has strapped soda
bottles to his chest like dynamite one
where rick and morty have flavorflave
style bling and then
one with morty and rick naked looking
like they're in front of the simpsons
house on evergreen terrace and then as
they squeeze out through the closing
portal the audio guys mixed in a little
fart sound like a you know squirting out
of a you know
now when jessica answers morty call look
her phone is still on the incoming call
screen which is a gaff comment in live
action production but here the animators
put it
in just as a reference to that gap
because it would have been easy enough
for them to animate it changing now we
learned rick has a rule about no
ocean passage because of his nemesis mr
nimbus a
two sexy ocean master based on namor
also a bit on aquaman
just these ocean superheroes who uh show
too much
he's voiced by dan harmon also notice
how in his clam shell one of those
tendrils is totally a dick
now it is implied that their conflict
was more recently embroiled back in
tales from the citadel the off-screen
ricklantis mix-up in which morty and
rick hooked up with mermaids which rick
later references this episode
oh i've already been to war with
atlantis when i d-dayed that mermaid
push i knew that was you
now we see some new opening credits that
include a shot of the family's heads
popping off and turning into spiders
just like in john carpenter's the thing
some are bad sentient mailboxes in
reality where the houses are also
mailboxes one home reading mail 4155
a little tease of the upcoming voltron
episode also a tease for this season's
vindicators episode you see rick trying
to resuscitate noob noob while above
some detached eyeball hangs and then one
where morty just putts
amazing rick extends a dinner table to
make room for all the stupid crap
they're gonna have to have on there also
maybe so he wants to sit as close to mr
nimbus
he also drags out an ocean-themed chair
that bumps over the wine
being the impetus for the whole wine in
the narnia pocket dimension storyline in
case you're wondering what was scented
from summer's line
it is let's lick tits i'm not sure why
lick was censored but whatever beth and
jerry have been exploring their sex life
dr wong suggested we experiment we've
been watching pornography
referencing dr wong the therapist voiced
by susan sarandon from the pickle rick
episode
who by the way also helps people who eat
poop mr
and rick reveals there are suicide
capsules in all of your teeth do what
you want with that yeah pretty
horrifying that he somehow snuck these
into all of their mouths
probably thinking that with enough
adventures they'll all become as
self-destructive as he is
so rick ages up wine and it's time
dilated pocket reality
so time moves faster in there it's like
a narnia thing i'm not a beaver who
believes in jesus christ
morty but yeah it's pretty much a narnia
thing of course referencing c
s lewis chronicles of narnia in which
time in the narnia reality moves faster
though like in this episode the rate of
the dilation isn't exact or consistent
and
rick refers to mr beaver in the series
being a christian allegory which it very
much is and we should note that this
dimensional portal is not the typical
green
swirling one and that's because this
narnia reality is not a dimension
parallel to c137
but a confined pocket reality within
this one kind of like rick's mic reverse
battery and yes this time dilated
dimension is also pretty similar to the
flaxsense dimension and invincible if
you watch that on amazon prime you
should it's awesome mr nimbus arrives on
this epic chariot that needs to flood
the street first and it's pulled by
these two dolphins
reigned by an octopus whose eyes glow as
headlights as two other octopi blow
these conch shells
and despite this obvious fanfare jerry
hilariously asked
is that mr nimmus now one of my favorite
design elements of mr nimbus
are his mini capes that he dramatically
throws off for no reason now you can see
them all layered on top of themselves
when he first arrives but he tosses off
the red one then the orange one then the
teal one as he walks up and then later
the pink one and then an overhead shot
all of them are scattered on the ground
there jerry says he's seen rick
a planet referencing last season's
children of mort episode
and jerry mocks the logic of mr nimbus
controlling the police
he controls police jerry right that
tracks in dumb world
i love rick's silent cringe as jerry
says in
dumb world so the cops fight and flee
and this happens real fast but you can
see the creepy animation of mr nimbus
feeling up
jerry the divots made by the palm there
and then one finger poke on the dismount
yikes and you gotta love mr nimbus
starfish assistant with a clamshell
briefcase a seaweed scarf booties and
then as always with rick and morty
characters
so morty shows jessica interdimensional
cable and it is set to the nintendo 69
channel at first i thought this could
have been the porn that beth and jerry
have been talking about watching
together but
later rick owns up to it all i do is eat
ass and 69 nintendos bro
so you know this must be his channel and
check out the recliner there it is still
extended that might be because rick had
just been sitting on it
during it and you know you only have so
many things you can do with your hands
right after you just kind of have to
wiggle out of the
sure i'm sorry that is gross and yeah
this is the n64 logo but the console is
the older nes since wearing a thong
ass in the dude's face showing how
they're doing the 69 position anyway we
gotta move on
hoovey is voiced by jim gaffigan and he
leaves his pregnant wife bova behind in
their peaceful farm to help morty's move
the wine back in the garage but when he
returns his farm has eroded the roof
that he was in the middle of repairing
based on his ladder propped up against
it before that's now collapsed
all the flowers are dead the curved tree
is dying
and now the wine boxes are covered by a
shrub he spins bova around like the
skeleton of mrs bates and psycho
and his son attacks him japheth when
were you born
yeah i love it what a weird sentence
like aaron knows his name
and he's there but he asks when he was
born i don't know i just think it's
weird as rick and nimbus negotiate
rick watches a video of summer in the
marianas trench slaying nimbuses guards
they include
sharks dolphins squids all of them have
six packs of course they do now morty
returns to find the farm green once
again
just unkempt the roof has been patched
just poorly
hoovy right never say his name
jesus christ why why is every old guy
super jacked yeah calling back the jack
story train conductor last season
notice how he knocks out a tooth and
leaves some morty's hair behind
these later become key relics to this
society in the future morty throws mud
in japheth's eyes and returns
vomits and just goes right back in to
find japheth much older
patch on the eye apparently having let
go of his vengeance let's check it out
the farm is thriving
yeah morty still calls him hoovy still
not getting that this is hoovey's son
but before we continue when's the last
time he got rewarded for brushing your
teeth i mean besides the obvious reward
of not getting cavities with
quips smart electric toothbrush good
habits can earn you great perks the quip
smart brush connects to the quip
app with bluetooth and lets you track
when and how well you brush
and improve your habits you earn points
for daily brushing and bonus points for
completing challenges
you can then redeem those points for
free rewards already have quip well
upgrade it with a smart motor and keep
the features you love sensitive sonic
vibrations two minute timer thirty
second pulses for a guided clean
and in addition to brush heads quip also
delivers fresh floss
toothpaste mouthwash and gum refills
every three months from just
five dollars shipping is free so you can
save money and skip the hustle and
bustle of in-store shopping join over
five million
mouths who use quip and save hundreds
compared to other bluetooth brushes when
you get a quip smart brush
for just 45 start getting rewards for
brushing your teeth today
go to get quip.com new rockstars right
now
to save ten dollars on equipped smart
electric toothbrush that's ten
dollars off a smart electric toothbrush
at get quip.com
new rockstars spell g-e-t-q-u
dot com slash new rock stars quip the
good habits company now japheth leaves
behind three suns one in red one in
green one in purple who has this
weird-looking
bird they end up slashing their palms
swearing a blood oath over a sigil of
morty's head impaled by a sword and as
they build a fortress around this portal
site their house behind them gets more
developed and that weakest brother in
purple
holds a boulder trap over it just in
case he comes back but just holding that
in place over time notice it makes them
more jacked and it all develops into a
heavily armed fortress akin to castle
black on the wall in game of thrones and
throughout this montage that shrub
hiding the wine is just for whatever
reason never touched even in the big
courtyard shot you can actually see that
wine crate even more exposed though no
one seems to care might be because they
left it as bait for his return
or they just hilariously did never tear
it down rick mentions whisper kitchen
frasier [ __ ] which the writer jeff
loveness cited as a reference he wanted
to put in
to how in the sitcom frasier they often
have fraser and niles whisper bickering
in the kitchen during the dinner party
now when morty returns again the
warriors arrows and boulders miss him as
he goes back to the portal but kills the
poor guard who alerted them so morty
arms up and returns the kingdom is now
in debate over whether their vigilance
was even worth it the portal site
is now directly in the middle of the
throne room that bird is now even
older it has elaborate plumage that rug
beneath the green king's feet shows the
three brothers heraldry love how above
the hearth is a portrait of their old
home and then on the side wall hangs a
portrait of their parents japheth and
whoever his wife was
so the prince who is complaining is
outcast and gets recruited by the
sorcerer who brings him to a cave marked
by runes
offers him spells to give him a reforged
sword that could be like the broken
blade and lord of the rings
and then you see these messages showing
how the other two king brothers die
leaving only his father left to kill the
sorcerer also applies leeches which is a
common middle-aged apothecary practice
intended for bloodletting improving
health and the outcast prince leads a
bloody rebellion killing his father only
to be stabbed in the back by the
sorcerer and then morty's portal
violently severs that warrior leading to
morty wrecking the place blasting all
the warriors i love how he tosses
grenades that if you go through frame by
frame
melt their eyeballs out of their skulls
morty's visor scans the wine
revealing that it is a chianti 237
cycles
16 alcohol by volume and he tosses his
levitation glove aside leading to that
gauntlet being recovered by this woman
similar to how in the terminator movies
cyberdyne systems use the recovered t800
arm to develop advanced technology and
make skynet possible mr nimbus mentions
another rick assistant
kyle hope we meet that guy morty finally
gets his kiss with jessica meanwhile the
narnia dimension evolves into a
technologically advanced society that is
fully
demonized morty the woman who recovered
the gauntlet also had recovered morty's
hair in that tooth back from that fight
with japheth her son adam is a
traveler who trains in this x-men style
danger room
that was probably the 90s x-men
references that jeff lovnis was
referencing in his tweet so adam becomes
this hardened adult
who suits up fueled by three others
liquefying their bodies
and it is his interest in the kitchen
that causes morty to drop the wine
opener that jessica later uses to stab
the guy's tube
and that broken suit causes him to age
up in age down from an old man to a baby
just like scott lang in avengers in game
actually jeff loveness is also writing
ant-man the was quantomania loveness
said that he voiced adam himself so in
his moment of death adam faces this
cosmic bird at the end of time perched
on a dying tree its roots wrapped around
a heart
this imagery is based on darren
aronofsky's the fountain which is what
morty was later referring to when he
said
strip down sundance sci-fi [ __ ]
morty's older gardener self says
you're early which is another kind of
trophy line at this point that we heard
the ancient one saying
in game you're about five years too
early but of course it's all a
simulation trick by an even more
advanced race of bovine ais that
replaced that race meanwhile mr nimbus
references rick's wife diane
if diane were alive today what was she
an established canadical backstory with
me you redlock
confirming that the backstory with diane
we saw in the season three premiere
might have been at least partly true
also notice how that line cut off there
they do a little trick here later in the
episode when morty escapes and we cut
back to rick he finishes this sentence
right where he left off
your mother screw this what am i even
doing so morty very quickly figures out
the flaw and the ai
confinement beams by tucking his arm in
and then he builds on that to wiggle out
during this thoughtful speech
don't give a [ __ ] let her go why did i
clone myself genitals
and rick arrives to help god why does
everyone go cyberpunk bird it's so
[ __ ]
hacked yeah that bird design may have
been a relic of that bird that we saw on
the shoulder of the king in this culture
it's just important to them
rick also might have been referring to
the way bird person evolved into a
cyberpunk form so when the bird blasts
rig notice how it sucks out all of his
cybernetic implants that we've seen
throughout the series including his
wrist gun the gadgets in his leg his
abdomen his shoulder
as well as taking his blaster and his
portal gun mr nimbus floods the place he
drops these bovine whales on the birds
and then they swim back through the gate
as they all fall in mr nimbus just
glides in on a little wave so as jessica
tells her story we see how the
authorities debate what to do with her
in the background you see these murals
depicting bova and japheth
meanwhile hoovey was erased from their
history probably because japheth hated
his father
and then japheth's three sons the bird
and then
at the bottom of that banner it reads
bound by blood referring to their blood
oath and then next to them the
insurrectionist son
and then adam and his mother the full
history of the species then we see the
invention of the a.i that leads to the
destruction of this whole bovine kind
with their skulls impaled on spears just
like they wanted to do to morty
based off of that sigil that they had oh
the irony and then floating past jessica
are that blood oath stone the grapes of
the wine
the tech gauntlet that enabled their
advancement and a cyberpunk bird summer
returns with a shell and blows it but
she should have destroyed it because it
powers up mr nimbus even more leading to
rick's arrest and in the post-credits
scene beth and jerry finally get that
threesome i love how on the doorknob
there it has mr nimbus's shell imprint
on it and then beth requests
please don't tell rich he wouldn't
understand yes he would
hinting that mr nimmus and rick's
quarrel might have begun as a lover's
dispute so that's everything i caught in
this episode of rick and morty you can
support our channel by checking out some
great merch options that we're offering
by going to newrockstarsmerch.com follow
me on instagram and twitter at eavos
follow and subscribe to new rockstars
and we'll see you next time bye
[Music]
you